vamos a hablar de motores porque se
anunciaron los cambios en las
competencias de la fórmula-1
específicamente estamos hablando de las
competencias sprint y que la federación
internacional de automovilismo anunció
que para el presente año tendrá un
cambio en el sistema de puntuación
dentro de la temporada las carreras
sprint se presentaron el año pasado en
tres fechas y sustituyan a las jornadas
de pool position de los días sábados al
igual que el año pasado se mantendrán
las tres fechas pero esta vez en los
circuitos de imola de austria y de
brasil pero cambiará su sistema de
puntuación hasta el año pasado solamente
recibían puntos los tres primeros
lugares es decir tres puntos para el
primero 2 para el segundo y 1 para el
tercero ahora serán 8 puntos a repartir
8 que ganará quien llegue en el primer
lugar y de ahí sucesivamente hasta la
octava posición por otro lado hay que
señalar que el piloto que lidera en las
cuales del viernes tendrá la ´pole
position´ durante el fin de semana pero
todas estas iniciativas que ya fueron
discutidas deben ser ratificadas por los
el próximo o dentro de algunas semanas
cuando se lleve a cabo el consejo del
motor